alors quelles sont les réactions dans le
secteur pour en parler nous sommes en
direct avec olivier occelli directeur de
l'office du tourisme de bordeaux en
direct également avec bruno cappellari
patron des chefs du restaurant
l'harmonie à sérignan dans l'hérault
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france pour
réagir donc à ces annonces et mesures
présentées par edouard philippe edouard
philippe qui appelle un col tourisme
fait probablement face à la pire épreuve
de son histoire moderne est ce que vous
avez clairement étaient rassurés
aujourd'hui on commence par vous olivier
occelli aimait écouter
oui en tout cas ces aides sont vraiment
à la hauteur de la crise que l'on
traverse aujourd'hui on peut dire que
voilà s'il ya des mesures à court terme
à moyen terme à long terme parce que la
période de reprise va être très longue
pour le tourisme donc oui ces annonces
ont été à la hauteur
autre réaction dont bruno cappellari
vous est on le rappelle un patron et
chef d'un restaurant on imagine que
c'est effectivement très compliqué
enfoncé un pour les restaurants
largement rassurés par les annonces du
premier ministre aujourd'hui a assuré
c'est pas vraiment le mot pour moi je
pense que je reste quand même un petit
peu sceptique je suis partagé entre la
joie est effectivement de retour les
collaborateurs nos clients
la joie de cuisine et parce que ça va
s'cauet métier maintenant un petit peu
la peur des contraintes qui peuvent nous
tomber dessus on n'a pas le cahier des
charges en bois ouvrir swaziland en un
peu plus de deux semaines donc ça va
être très compliqué il faut espérer que
tout se passe bien jusque là déjà il
voit comme un point et retrouver notre
clientèle de tpe olivier occelli cette
inquiétude de la part de notre ami
restaurateur de ne pas retrouver la
clientèle de pour voiler elle est fondée
oui tout à fait on est dans
l'expectative de en effet de cette
réouverture avec des conditions qui vont
être
compliqué c'est vrai que sur des
destinations comme bordeaux la clientèle
internationale ne sera pas présente sur
cet été donc ça sera quand même des
grands manques à gagner en effet pour
pour le secteur ça veut dire quoi
concrètement messieurs que ce plan pour
vous il est très franco français pour
l'instant
on rappelle quand même des points
importants chômage partiel jusqu'à fin
septembre cours à l'activité partielle
impossible jusqu'à fin 2020 la sphère
des tickets restaurant qu'on va pouvoir
ça paraît anodin comme l'expliqué
edouard philippe mais voilà qu'on pourra
utiliser le week-end avec des plafonds
élevé ça reste très français pour vous
aussi trop français peut-être bruno
cappellari oui c'est tout aussi français
que la firme a toujours qu'on nous a
fait faire effectivement le 14 mars en
nous annonçant à 19h15 lui il fallait
fermer on a la même problématique pour
la réouverture
c'est moi c'est vraiment ce qui
m'inquiète le plus en haut je suis en
bord de mer donc on a une grosse
clientèle d'étrangers qu'on aura pas
cette année on va réouvrir avec le
personnel puisque on ne peut pas
travailler sans malheureusement on
fabrique tout nombreux resteront avec de
la matière première le frêche et des
denrées périssables
on va se retrouver avec certainement 100
% des charges avec peut-être 52 40 % de
la clientèle
donc ça va être quelque chose qui va
fort très bien géré et certainement des
charges supplémentaires avec nathan
forcément des visières des masques des
gld
je pense qu'on ne s'est pas encore assez
pour vraiment explosé de joie sur cette
réouverture qui pourrait effectivement
que tel étrangères vous avez eu des
informations pour le moment
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas mais
peut-être que je vais rester optimiste
si je reste optimiste en juillet-août
qu'on arrive déjà évident c'est sur la
fin de la saison quand même faut quand
même se dire que le récit les saisons
sont de plus en plus courtes et de l'an
plus compliqué pour tout le monde
en effet il ya eu un manque à gagner
très fort sur le printemps et les lignes
aériennes malheureusement son sont
complètement stoppée et il va falloir
des mois plusieurs mois pour que les
lignes aériennes reprennent alors il ya
quand même une bonne nouvelle on l'a
swing peut-être pas assez c'est que les
français sont clairement incités à la il
ya eu d'ailleurs un rétropédalage du
gouvernement puisque ministre de la
santé nous avait dit surtout ne
réservait pas les vacances et là ils
voient venir nous disent ici vous pouvez
y aller est allé en france on vous
garantit même des remboursement complet
en cas d'empêchement à cause de
l'épidémie c'est une bonne chose ça
notamment sur le bassin d'arcachon
on rappelle que vous gérez les hôtels
les restaurations olivier occelli sinon
je gère pas mes chiots relier en tout
cas avec les acteurs du tourisme n'ont
pas de problèmes locaux oui c'est une
très bonne chose
nous on mise beaucoup sur la clientèle
nationale on revoit toute notre offre
notamment de visites guidées de tous les
acteurs du tourisme refusent remettent
en oeuvre leurs offres pour cette
clientèle nationale et même pour la
clientèle locale le tourisme de
proximité pour les week-ends à venir
on attend beaucoup de ce tourisme de
proximité vient soudain entendu ça ne
compensera pas les manques à gagner au
niveau international mais on espère que
les français vont vouloir découvrir leur
ville leur territoire est en tout cas on
met tout en oeuvre pour cela et bruno
cappellari ça vous a quick soulager
cette incitation clairement à consommer
français cet été encouragés tout
simplement les français à rester sur le
territoire et à réserver
oui bien sûr bien sûr qu'il y en aura un
véritable rôle à nous de le recevoir
comme il se doit de leur présenter dans
une région nos produits au producteur
[Musique]
il ya des travaux manifestement chez
vous ça prépare certainement là la
réouverture est ce que olivier occelli
les restaurants ont fait des
propositions pour s'adapter on sait que
ça parfois on nous parle de voilà comme
dans d'autres pays de plexiglas entre
les tables on imagine que c'est pas
vraiment de rentrer dans l'esprit très
très français la convivialité
c'est certain la restauration comme
alesi allez-y vous êtes plus à même de
répondre ça correspond pas tout à fait
ou est ce que les clients viennent
rechercher dans des établissements plus
tôt la convivialité et la proche même
envers le personnel de service qui va
leur présenter le vin les assiettes les
produits les donc si on doit commencer à
mettre des petits glace entre les
clients comme je lui passais sur
certains réseaux des cloches qui tombent
du plafond des je sais pas si c'est
vraiment ce que viennent rechercher les
clients au restaurant la dernière
question est pour vous puisque vous êtes
en liaison avec on le rappelle ses
hôtels autour de bordeaux le versant
d'arcachon pour qu'on ait prévu
clairement la réouverture est ce qu on a
déjà une petite idée pour même écouter
des hôtels sont déjà ouverts sur
bordeaux en tout cas il est possible de
venir pour séjourner un week end dans la
zone des 100 km aujourd'hui et plus tard
on espère sur juillet-août de les hôtels
vont réouvrir très certainement au fur
et à mesure des semaines à venir des
opérateurs prévoient de ré ouvrir dans
le courant du mois de juin
donc on est prêt pour ce tourisme de
proximité ce tourisme national dans les
semaines à venir
capelli d'avoir été avec nous